whether you're a hybrid or multi-cloud
architect learn how to manage containers
with Google kubernetes engine and anthos
with the hybrid multi-cloud learning
path this path was designed to guide you
no matter where you are in your Learning
Journey start at the first stop if
you're new to Google cloud or jump in at
a different stop if you're enhancing an
existing skill set
the first few stops will help you learn
the fundamentals of core infrastructure
architecting with Google kubernetes
engine and architecting hybrid Cloud
infrastructure with anthos learn from
Google Cloud experts via instructor-led
training or take advantage of the
flexibility of on-demand the choice is
completely up to you Google Cloud offers
multiple modalities so you can learn how
you want to whether on demand or
instructor-led you will gain access to
the same course content and Labs so you
won't miss out on a hands-on experience
practice what you've learned polish your
skills and earn skill badges show the
world that you and your team can create
deploy secure and manage Cloud resources
and workloads in Google kubernetes
engine
use skill badges to gain recognition or
to help you land a new role
looking to continue learning or for a
different topic area Google Cloud offers
learning paths spanning across the
solution pillars
from beginner to Advanced this
comprehensive learning path will guide
you along your Google Cloud hybrid
multi-cloud Journey time to get started
foreign